Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, this is going
to be my Korra episode 3 video.
If you’re a night owl like me then you saw
this drop early on Amazon.
For some reason the episodes will post there
right after midnight pacific time.
They’re not free, it’s not a leak or anything.
But usually Nick doesn’t post them till
about 5AM.
So it’s a nice bonus.
New round of the giveaway starts now, all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
But starting with top 5 moments -
Number 5 - Prince Wu’s Coronation
Starting with the dance of the badger moles.
Best dance ever, but it reminded me of the
Badger Mole song from last airbender.
That was from book 2 episode 2.
Cave of two lovers.
Which is also the episode with the secret
tunnel song.
They actually sang that song at san diego
comic con, dee bradley baker was there for
another show so he came by and did it again.
They’re very clearly positioning Wu as someone
who’s completely disconnected from people.
Just totally tuned out from reality.
I flipped a little when he walked up to Kuvira
and pretty clearly sexually harassed her.
I loved the way they very clearly want us
to think Kuvira is evil, but make us root
for her.
Like she has the wicked grin and the creepy
music cue as she makes fun of Wu.
But you want to laugh at Wu.
Maybe laugh nervously.
That is a pretty creepy face.
The Bolin Eska meetup was priceless.
I think she might only be a minor character
in this book, and because Bolin is with Opal,
who’s totally awesome.
I don’t expect any of the typical love triangle
stuff to happen.
Like if this were book 1 or 2, Bolin would
be like Mako trying to balance two women.
I’m glad they’re not doing that this time.
I don’t think anyone was surprised with
Kuvira’s scary rhetoric.
She always gets what she wants…
And we finally got some more context about
what happened in Zhaofu after the death of
the earth queen.
Suyin wanted to wait it out and Kuvira charged
in determined to fix things.
That’s why, as bolin put it so eloquently,
she’s just like Korra.
She’s the gung-ho empress.
I guess we should call her now.
Empress Kuvira of the New Earth Empire.
I know a lot of you have pointed out similarities
to Chin the Conqueror.
The first Emperor of China.
I know everyone was hoping to see Kyoshi warriors
at the ceremony, but she did get the Kyoshi
Freedom Medal.
And then proceeded to crush it.
I like the metaphor in Kuvira crushing a symbol
of freedom.
The whole ceremony was intended to split people,
so don’t feel bad if you came out rooting
for Kuvira.
That’s what Mike and Bryan want.
They don’t want there to be a readily identifiable
villain right now.
Obviously Kuvira will be the ultimate villain,
but not in the traditional Dark Avatar sense.
Number 4 - Everybody Hates Wu
Mako finally let’s him have it in the Palace
restaurant.
Just to be clear, they were still in republic
city.
The palace was just a restaurant modeled to
look like the royal palace.
I almost cried a little bit when I saw Bosco,
remember how the earth queen implied she ate
him.
I guess it’s fitting he appear stuffed in
a restaurant that looks like his old home.
I love the way Bryke has added memorabilia
from last airbender to korra scenes.
Like the Aang carnival games in book 2.
I would totally go to an avatar themed restaurant.
Maybe we can get them to do that.
Even a little hole in the wall tea shop.
Kuvira is the star and it seems like the only
people who understand what’s really going
on are the politicians like Suyin and Tenzin.
Even President Reiko was suprised when she
refused to lay down power.
This is going to be a big problem for Korra
when she tries to bring balance to the Earth
Empire.
I guess we should just call it that for now.
Number 3 - The Other Nations Are Powerless
To Stop Kuvira
Varrick explained that the Earth Empire had
precious metals that the other nations needed
to survive.
So all Kuvira has to do to put pressure on
them is cut off the supply of metal from their
mines.
There’s also that giant mechanical army
she has.
The highspeed rail Varrick constructed gives
her an fast way to mobilize her army too.
That’s how she’ll be able to defend her
borders.
Speaking of which, she’s going after zhaofu
next.
She’ll make them sign the treaty or go down
fighting.
That’s probably why Suyin is hanging her
head here looking all sad.
It also looks like she’s in the body of
a mech, I think I saw pictures of Water Tribe
mechs too.
They might have been from the video game,
but I’m guessing all of the nations have
access to them via Future Industries.
In case you missed it too, Varrick explained
that Kuvira forced President Reiko to pardon
him, so it’s possible she did the same thing
for Asami’s Father so he’d help design
new mechs for her army.
So Kuvira has what seems like her own mahattan
project team of scientists building things
for her and economically she’s got the rest
of the world by the balls.
Number 2 - Varrick is Exploiting Spirit Energy
As weird as that looks, he’s probably just
using it to power the engine.
I didn’t notice any extra special weaponry.
They’ll probably find a way to harness the
spiritual energy the vines give off and use
it as power for their tech.
Not just the rail, but the mechs, probably
some pretty badass giant weapons we haven’t
seen yet.
In a sense, they’re cannibalizing the spirit
world to power their innovation.
We know the vines serve as a home for the
spirits, but it’s also possible they’re
necessary for their survival.
Like fast forward and you see all the spirits
slowly dying off because the Earth Empire
has used up that natural resource.
Or perverted it in some way.
That look on Varrick’s face, is not a good
look.
The interesting thing is that I think by the
end of the season, once a final compromise
is reached, there will be some sort of technological
synergy between the spirit world and the physical
world.
Like, they’ll find a positive version of
whatever Varrick is doing.
It kind of reminds me of clean energy with
a magical twist.
Like using Nethicite to power stuff in Final
Fantasy 13.
and my number 1 moment - Korra and Toph Swamp
Time
I wish every time could be swamp time with
Toph.
I like that they spent what looked like a
couple hours of Toph kicking Korra’s but
before Toph finally explained there was metal
fragments left in her body.
She probably sensed those in last week’s
episode.
Toph is great with the tough love.
It really is classic Toph, they totally nailed
her with the writing.
It was like watching last airbender Toph.
Favorite Toph Quotes were:
“I’m the Original Beifong” - meaning
she’s the original grumpy beifong
“I forgot how much I loved tormenting the
avatar”
and “You’re the worst Avatar I’ve ever
worked with” and then she completely buys
back her joke saying yeah yeah, I’ve only
known one other Avatar.
I also loved that she made fun of the other
swamp benders.
Implying that at some point she’d kicked
all their butts.
It wasn’t so much funny, but she does have
that very Yoda Jedi Master moment when she
explains that because she’s deeply connected
to the earth and the earth is everywhere,
she’s connected to everyone all over the
place.
She can’t see Lin and Suyin, but she can
sense them.
So in a way, she probably knows about everything
that’s been going on since Book 1.
She’s trying to make Korra see the big picture.
That’s why she made light of her time as
police cheif and all of Korra’s victories.
Toph feels like, in the grand scheme of the
universe, none of that little stuff matters.
Regardless of how little you think Harmonic
Convergence was.
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and do you think Kuvira is going to use the
spirit vines to power big big weapons eventually?
Overall I gave the episode a solid A minus
for feeling like a great classic last airbender
parable.
And a great Yoda Toph episode.
She such a big character, I feel like it would
be wrong to give the big lessons to someone
else.
The tough love stuff is just for laughs, I
think by the end of the season she’ll take
a more active role.
I would be pissed if she vaporized into spirit
form like Yoda.
The story is more interesting now than it’s
ever been.
Kuvira is like Sephiroth and Varrick is like
Shinra.
They’re exploiting nature in the name of
progress and pushing their way of life on
everyone with the threat of voilence.
So of course Korra is going to have to stop
her from taking the world in a bad direction.
As for all the new bits of technology, I think
part of the balance theme this season will
be them learning to use all those things without
hurting people.
Even if the spirit vine batteries don’t
hurt the spirits, they’ll still probably
be used for weapons of mass destruction.
I’m loving how Bryke is testing our loyalties
to certain characters and I can’t wait to
see how Korra gets back into action.
I do think she’ll heal herself.
Even if she doesn’t pull the metal out,
she’ll find a way to turn it into a positive.
Don’t forget, I’ll announce this week’s
giveaway winner in my Q&A tomorrow.
So leave all your questions.
I’ve got a few extra videos I have to get
out this weekend but I’ll try to get a Bonus
Avatar video done.
Maybe like a classic Toph video.
That would be fun.
Right now click here for the Q&A, I’ll update
the annotation as soon as I post it and click
here for my episode 2 video.
Thanks for watching, now let’s all high
five and I’ll see you guys tonight!